on arrête tout l'arcade nom alors je
comprend pas le projet c'est quoi
comment tu t'appelles loucas louca déjà
tu va redescendre de deux étages
seulement tu fais quoi dans l'habitude
l'est pas dans la coiffure ration marc
dosch aux sports dans le sport c'est
quoi tu va remplacer kelly ce soir toi
t'es pas tu te mets là bas tu dis rien
ça ira très bien c'est que c'est monfils
jure sur la tête de bien sûr non mais
c'est vrai qu'être s'est il amusé
quel est ton projet capillaire s'est pas
laissé abattre et ça y est tu veux pas
que je coupe tout de suite les cheveux
moi non
[Applaudissements]
alors en avant les boeufs
coface
de nombreuses voix y aider à mon père
ouais c'est pour vite finir comme ça ces
chauffeurs toi tu en prends pas faire et
les paires beau et il est hyper beau et
les mots mais je profite vois tu
profites un foulard alors là je vais te
dire être tu profites un peu trop là
franchement là là frérot mais ont
franchement tu devrais mais tout allait
comme si on dira tapis à tapis d'entrée
on dirait qu'on va bien on va dire
bienvenue planches de bois oui c'est
rien du tout vous êtes fous comme un
élément physique
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'est ce qu'elle m'a ramené à le
vrai
effet du des repousses c'est pas
possible des couleurs quoi est ce que tu
veux être un assistant en nationale b
tant d'assistanat ont fait un piquetage
avec un fondu à l'essai photo capables
installez ça tu vas passer avec mathieu
au bac
ok novak a valu à la la la la
mais un champ non peu plus loin alors
c'est qui qui va alors lui lui chez mon
coloriste c'est un des meilleurs alors
que tu voies pour lui toi à la mois déjà
pour moi il faut refaire entièrement la
repousse et non pas les racines ce que
19 jours n'importe quoi les racines
center enfin les repousses parce que
l'habit couleurs comme ça ces provinces
à des canons dirhams à la barre ses
bigoudis les goûts j'ai alors regardé
comme ici n'est pas bon
magnifique mais 100 fois plus beau c'est
la mode
ils étaient cent fois mieux comme ça et
là c'est pas fini deschamps fois plus
haut
[Applaudissements]
avec la même
à
c'est bon
mais dallas
je faire dégrader progressivement fait
tout seul dans le trou comme moi face à
ces trois fois mais j'en ai déjà fait
main dès ce week-end
[Rires]
allez mandela
[Applaudissements]
alors là
[Musique]
voilà
tu veux être un homme
et je crois qu'il faut que je le fasse
ici et là sur mathieu bellahsen physique
c'est mon métier sur isabelle du coup tu
vaux johnny en des temps un atelier
coiffure
oh la la c'est très très bien
non mais ça va pas du tout c'est pas mal
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est bon c'est la casse et c'est
un mec comme je le dis à chaque fois il
suit les dossiers
il laisse pas les familles en détresse
il est tout le temps avec eux et il fait
un travail formidable et tout le monde
lui aussi à lui vraiment il fait
l'unanimité quand j'ai dit qu'ils
avaient pascal ce soir tout le monde
était comme ingrédient se fait abattre
chaque fois que tu viens ça cartonne tu
vas voir plus souvent et ben moi tu veux
dire que tu mets alors je pourrais
prendre la place de gao d'arrêt jaloux
c'est la jalousie qui parle pas il était
jaloux de pascal il est beau pascal lamy
a quand même bien je pense quand même
bien il m a tant que je veux dire battus
même année qu'elle habitait garde
cette baisse va connaître un peu plus
pascal pascal et est beau il est beau
très beau sourire je vous regarde moi
j'adorais me toi comme mr bah quand son
fils pas justement d'abord le piste
pascal fontaine ce qui étonne en public
par hasard je les prie dans le public
regardez l'option pascal chickens c'est
tout ça est bien le fils de pascal
fontaine maintenant c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
chabanais d'ebola moi je tombe très bien
même vraiment très bien moi elle me dit
comment vous pourriez être sage arrière
arrière grand mère qu'elle achevait en
40 ans arrière seulement
[Applaudissements]